video went viral yesterday
on the streets of new york
an animal rights activist versus a
regular guy eating a kebab and this
video i think this sums up the
difference between the left and the
right in america
[Music]
he's not saying anything he's just
eating
this is it this is what politics looks
like right now to the generic voter
the libs are the screaming
shrieking
hyena animal rights activists
losing their minds because a man is
eating a street kebab on the sidewalk in
new york and then the conservatives look
like the just the guy in the t-shirt
with the sunglasses trying to enjoy his
kebab quietly
not not really all that provocative just
eating his lunch that's what it looks
like right now
it didn't always look like that but
that's what it looks like right now
when the libs
wail and shriek and cry about the
importance of of having five-year-olds
watch drag queen shows
they look like the shrieking animal
rights lady when the libs
shriek and cry and scream about the
importance of flooding the country with
illegal aliens they look like the crazy
animal rights lady when the libs wear 17
different masks and have 152 injections
of the fouchy algae they look like the
crazy animal rights lady and then all
the rest of us are here and what do we
say most conservatives right now or
they're not articulating some super
ethereal academic
political ideology they're just saying
hey maybe don't chop the kids genitals
off maybe don't
or if you're gonna like wait a little
while at least right huh maybe let's not
kill all the kids it's not in the
constitution and it's probably wrong
don't you think
hey
i don't know i maybe the fifth shot of
the experimental mrna drug maybe i don't
need that to prevent the mild cough they
seem really really reasonable and
moderate right now which the the right
wing does not always seem but it does
right now that's why they're winning
over people like joe rogan
that's why they're winning over the
middle of the road voter
that's why liz cheney has a little bit
of a career right now she's not taking
any votes away from the right from the
republicans she's taking votes away from
the democrats
because she is effectively a democrat
and she's attacking trump but she's
prying off a decent percentage of the
moderate democrats that's why the polls
are showing if she were to run as for
president in 2024
she would she would single-handedly
swing the election to trump against
biden
speaking of eating this is a story i've
been waiting to get to for a while
and cnn has given me the opportunity
headline from cnn
meal worm seasoning scientists explore
creepy crawly flavoring to satisfy
meat cravings
would you like some meaty savory
mealworm powder seasoning with your food
it's a question you might soon be
hearing at the dinner table or at least
that's the hope of the scientists at
south korea's wonk wang university
that's right
the the research that they're working on
is a response to the dietary demands of
a growing global population in the
looming climate crisis and the argument
is
that because of the sun monster and
because people are having babies
we all have to eat bugs
there has been a really weird push from
the libs to make us all eat bugs there
was that video that came out a couple of
months ago that of all the celebrities
eating bugs
there are articles that pop up in the
mainstream media constantly talking
about how we need to eat crickets now we
need to eat meal worms we have to do it
why first of all when we talk about the
growing population the population in the
west is dying the united states has had
a dying population for 50 years so our
population is not growing that's why we
have to flood the country with illegal
aliens to art and legal immigrants for
that matter to artificially proper
economy up so the population growth is
not a big problem and the idea that the
sun monster is forcing us to
to eat
bugs is insane if anything a little
extra heat a little extra sunshine is
going to improve conditions for ranching
and farming
so what's this all about
what this is all about
is not
the sun monster or any of the doomsday
predictions that the libs always have
global warming global cooling the
population bomb remember that they're
talking they're worried about population
now 50 years ago in 1970 the libs
predicted in a very famous book by paul
ehrlich called the population bomb
that
the the world population within the
ensuing the the following 10 years would
grow and it would cause mass famine and
this was unavoidable and that's why we
needed forced sterilization and
contraception and that didn't happen
today the world population has doubled
malnutrition is at an all-time low
so that that was all just fake news but
whatever it is the doomsday predictions
of the global warming and the global
cooling and the population bomb and all
the rest of it and the ozone layer and
acid rain and all the other things
they don't ever destroy the world
we're now several years into aoc's
prediction the world's going to end in
10 years i think we're going to be fine
we're now well past prince charles's
prediction that the world was going to
end a couple of years ago
what is this about the reason they want
us to eat bugs is because it's gross
the reason they want us to eat bugs is
the same reason that catholics don't
it's not the same reason but it's the
same principle as to why catholics don't
eat meat on fridays it's the same
principle why people of all religious
backgrounds fast sometimes or eat eat
food that can be bitter or unpleasant at
some times for for the purposes of
spiritual discipline the reason that
they want us to eat bugs is because of
how yucky they are because it breaks a
taboo
it's it's not that we need to eat the
bugs to save the planet and as a
consequence of that it's going to break
our taboos the libs want us to break the
taboos because the libs don't like
western culture and they don't like our
traditional ways of life and they don't
like our traditional religion and they
want us to take part in their new weirdo
culture that's based on their weirdo new
age environmentalist religion and so to
be inducted into that and to train in a
spiritual discipline for that they want
us to eat the bugs there is
zero reason economically ecologically no
reason in the west especially in america
that we need to eat the bugs they just
want us to do it so that we're in the
cult with them
it's the bugs are much more a symbol
than they are a source of protein elon
musk just made a great observation about
this elon musk who is a big supporter of
renewable electric energy obviously
makes a lot of money on electric cars
elon musk who believes in global warming
and climate change
during a recent energy conference in
norway musk pointed out quote
some additional exploration of oil and
gas resources is warranted at this time
so unlike a lot of the other
environmentalist libs he's saying no no
we're not just going to get off of gas
and oil he says realistically i think we
need to use oil and gas in the short
term because otherwise civilization will
crumble one of the biggest challenges
the world has ever faced is the
transition to sustainable energy and to
a sustainable economy this will take
some decades to complete
great observation and it reminds us why
the libs are erecting all those stupid
windmills that kill the birds and don't
really produce any energy green energy
doesn't really work okay when you look
at the efficiency when you look at the
energy output it is absolutely nothing
compared to oil and gas and certainly
compared to nuclear power if the libs
were really just interested in
generating abundant cheap sustainable
energy they would build nuclear power
plants and yet the libs are not doing
that they're vehemently opposed to that
if the libs wanted
cheap abundant energy that contrary to
popular belief is not going to run out
anytime soon
probably any time at all
they would use fossil fuels
but that's not what they want what the
libs are really after is making us kind
of sacrifice making us feel the pinch
making us go through a kind of spiritual
discipline just like eating the bugs
they want us to
to
turn off turn off our energy and to stop
traveling as far and to stop doing as
much and to stop using gas and to not
even consider doing nuclear energy
because it hurts when they build those
windmills
they're not building a source of
sustainable energy they're they're just
building a religious icon
it's it's it's just the modern version
of an ancient egyptian obelisk with a
weird little spinny thing on top that's
what it's about the primary function of
the of the windmills and all of the
other monuments to environmentalism
is as a symbol is as a monument to the
new kind of cult the new kind of
religion well we used to build big
crosses we used to build statues of
christ the redeemer while we used to
build
even outside of christianity we used to
build ziggurats and and pyramids and
giant weird obelisks now we build these
monuments to the new gods of
environmentalism it's just a weird
creepy cult and it drives people just as
nuts as the
animal rights activists screaming at the
shish kebab guy on the streets of new
york i'm so glad you liked that clip now
you got to ring that bell subscribe i
know we hit a million subscribers i want
to hit one quintillion i know it's
ambitious we can do it ring the bell
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you